près dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
inédite et face à des conséquences
économiques qui s'annoncent très grave
alors faut-il annuler les dettes
africaines
pour en parler nous sommes avec nos deux
invités mj des la guerra député lt comme
liberté territoire de la 9e
circonscription des français établis
hors de france bonsoir à vous merci
d'être en direct avec nous à ses côtés
pour en parler mac ou dia diouf
géopolitologue cordes coordonnateur
pardon du collectif sortir du franc cfa
bonsoir à vous merci également d'être en
direct donc cette réunion un des cinq
présidents qui demande qu avant
l'annulation de la dette des dettes
plutôt aux africaines est ce que c'est
une demande légitime pour vous amis
gidel garrabe absolument la la dette
africaine est une est une
comment dire est un serait l'annulation
serait un ballon d'oxygène qu'on
pourrait offrir aux aux états africains
notamment en matière budgétaire
quand on sait par exemple qu'un pays
comme le ghana l'aneth le remboursement
de sa dette annuelle ça représente cette
fois le budget de la santé
donc il faut il faut absolument parvenir
à trouver des voies pour redonner cette
puissance budgétaire aux pays africains
pour investir dans leur santé investir
dans les infrastructures sanitaires dans
leur éducation etc pour faire face aux
défis à venir celui de la crise du
coronavirus mais au delà défis de
l'éducation des filles de la culture le
défi de la sécurité le défi des
infrastructures donc
donc voila nous on plaide en tout cas
moi je fais partie mais parlementaire
qui plaît de manière très forte pour
qu'on en arrive à pas simplement une un
rééchelonnement ou alors une
transformation de cette dette non une
annulation pure et simple
on vend on enverra en tout cas les
arguments pendant ce débat on va
voir la vie de makou dia diouf vous êtes
d'accord avec angie de el guerrab il
faut tout simplement annuler la dette
n'y a plus de nuances de votre côté
effectivement de mon côté il ya plus de
nuances alors déjà en fait il faut
mettre il faut mettre les soudards dans
leur contexte
on a des chefs d'état africains qui
demandent on va dire d'un assaut de la
ddip les africains mais sur le composé
au départ et maquereau qui pose le débat
et de l'éducation sete à la dette et moi
ce qu'il sait qui c'est qui me dérange
c'est que si vous souvenez bien je
voudrais faire un petit retour en
arrière
le 2 décembre 2009 les chefs d'état
africains ce robinet à dakar lors nous
sommes d'une conférence sur la dette et
donc qui se sont vantés d'être des pays
endettés et donc toi trois mois après en
fait quelques mois après on le voit
c'est une chef d'état réclamée en tout
cas demandé une génération de la dette
qu'ils n'obtiendront pas et donc moi
c'est que ce qui me gêne bien entendu
que je suis comme tout le monde je suis
d'accord que l'afrique soit en fait
soutenu face à l'artiste que comme 19 ce
qui me gêne en arrivant c'est la méthode
aujourd'hui les africains sont endettés
pas visage de la france mais vis-à-vis
de la chine
donc si elle demanda à faire il ne faut
surtout pas comme un maquereau il faut
aller vers l'asie est pour le moins
j entends pas en fait nos chefs d'état
africains faire une démarche que dit
bleu clair vers les partenaires chinois
et donc je me dis est ce que tout ça ne
serait ce pas une façon de enfin
mystifier la réputation africaine
donc voilà donc bien entendu je suis
pour la liberté de la dédicace africain
mais la méthode en tout cas qu'ils
avaient préconisé par des chefs d'état
comme alassane ouattara comme macky sall
du sénégal et la méthode cette méthode
homogène alors justement makhoudia dit
où je vous propose d'écouter le
président kenyan qui lui aussi justement
fait référence d'une certaine manière à
la chine
il est donc naturel de nous aider
dit il écoutez le c'est un phénomène qui
est né hors d'afrique et qui pourtant
frappe l'afrique le plus durement
il est donc naturel de nous aider voilà
m jid el guerrab le président kenyan qui
fait référence aussi à cette dette
vis-à-vis également de la chine donald
trump lui aussi d'ailleurs dit il
faudrait faire payer la chine concernant
l'afrique vous êtes d'accord avec ce
postulat ou au contraire tout le monde
doit s'y mettre
européens en tête le premier aujourd'hui
la première puissance qui détient
effectivement la dette africaine 40% de
la dette africaine
alors que la france s'est à peine 10%
c'est la chine est donc effectivement
moi je suis d'accord avec le président
du collectif quand il dit que
effectivement le l'enjeu il est plus il
s'est déplacé l'enjeu maintenant est des
plus de se désendetter à l'égard des
pays asiatiques comme la chine que des
pays européens mais comme je viens de
l'expliquer si vous vous désendetter de
manière massive via le club le club de
rome et caetera et et que vous permettez
à ces états d'avoir un peu plus
d'oxygène budgétaire pour pouvoir avoir
d d d d investissement un peu plus fort
dans l'eure dans leur domaine notamment
sanitaires
voilà ça fera quelques milliards en plus
qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas jeter d'un
revers de main mais c'est vrai que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est est ce que la
chine va accepter aujourd'hui on en est
pas à l'annulation en est simplement un
moratoire
il ya un accord de toutes les grandes
puissances pour dire pendant un an deux
ans on arrête de payer la dette
on arrête de payer le traitement suel
qu'on doit à nos anonyme sachant que
dans la dette
il ya la dette publique détenue par les
états mis à la dette aussi privé et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde
effectivement comment est structuré
cette dette
on voit deux
nair très clair que la dette privée la
dette chinoise aujourd'hui constitue une
grosse partie une grosse part du lion
effectivement là on va faire un peu de
pédagogie
mako dia diouf comme le souligne
monsieur el guerrab la dette privée et
la dette bilatérale africaine et ce
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
évidemment
alors effectivement je suis d'accord
avec ça c'était pas la même chose
maintenant il faut en fait de garder des
choses on peut en profondeur si vous le
regardez bien on a comme des chefs
d'état qui se sont endettés pour des
projets défend le fort qu'eux donc déjà
le garde pour les bonnes questions
pourquoi aujourd'hui l'afrique a légué
alors moi je peux parler un peu des pays
de la zone franc cfa parce que je le
connais parce que ces pays là sont sous
la domination coloniale de français qui
empêcherait de toute marge de manoeuvre
et là je cite les deux en fait benoît
patris talent qui dit on finance notre
note développement l'inde et noir et
même il s'en vante
ils s'en vantent les chefs d'état
africains se vendent à fait décent des
arguments que le fait que nos
partenaires nous tel de l'argent c'est
parce qu'on est très très bien géré donc
tout ça n'est pas sérieux
maintenant je ne veux pas non plus qu'on
part des chinois le doute mais c'est
parce que j'ai compris que dans les
propos de macron c'était voilà on voit
en fait tous les curseurs dans les
chinois que les affidés table tous les
chinois la question il est plus
compliqué la tâche
aujourd'hui c'est de dire si les
africains sont d'accord pour dire que
cette dette est injuste et illégitime
il ya une solution toute simple il peut
faire défaut donc c'est à dire en fait
je faisais des cdec certains vu l'eau
fait dans l'histoire donc déjà dit
qu'elles ne sont pas en fait les 1er 2
m2 et deuxièmement aujourd'hui on est en
été comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
auprès d'acteurs de trouver ou pas c'est
vraiment des activités qui viennent en
afrique tête de l'argent c'est taxer ces
structures sont aujourd'hui pour la pour
l'internaute
ils sont à merci pour nous faire les
proches je vais parler affaires de
gamins ils sont en effet pu faire du
trophy est une autre ils sont surtout
pas la géologie
dans une logique en tout cas
d'annulation de la dette
maintenant pour les états notamment en
fait la chine la france des sous sont
très simples moi j'ai écrit récemment un
communiqué pour dire que si la france
veut bien aider les africains de
nathalie une bonne chose mais comme que
la france commence par rendre aux
afriques aux africains les milliards
d'euros que la fin d'autres pays
africains
le franc cfa l'un des maîtres du franc
cfa
c'est un conte contemporain à sion qui
est doté à milliards la phrase tous les
intéressés font pour les africains pour
les soulager
alors je parle des pays de l'est moins
donc tout ça n'est pas n'est pas sérieux
d'être voilà soit la dette
on a eu des et moi je suis plus de dire
ça mais on n'aura pas d'émulation donc
je pense qu'on débat pour rien le
moratoire d'accord on l'aura mais
l'annulation
je ne crois pas parce que tout le monde
le sait tous ceux qui sont attachés au
aujourd'hui ils sont l'affairé de tous
faire des affaires ils sont en effet que
faire en tout cas c'est vrai que les
banques et les institutions privées
prête rarement y compris à nous simples
particuliers pour rien mj belles grappes
je vais je vais sélectionner un petit
passage de ce qu'a dit notre ami mais
coup dia diouf parfois c'est vrai que
l'afrique jeu je parle sous votre
contrôle c'est vous qui l'avez dit voilà
se vante de faire des dettes pour des
raisons parfois loufoques je me fais
l'avocat du diable pourquoi l'europe et
irait alors qu'elle même est en grande
difficulté on a une une dette qui est à
100 % du pib aujourd'hui annulerait la
dette de l'afrique alors voilà que
parfois ne gère pas les choses peut-être
là j'interprète peut-être vos propos
monsieur diouf mais comme un bon père de
famille finalement mais monsieur gnouf
tous les états ont besoin de dette il
n'y a pas ça n'existe pas un état qui
fonctionnerait sans dette la dette c'est
une nécessité pour moi est simple 3 non
mais non mais parce que quand on dit si
demain on annule la dette africaine et
ses états ça va pas les empêcher d'aller
s'endetter par ailleurs auprès
d'américains d'indiens
deux chinois etc deux russes pourquoi
parce que un état structurellement
fonctionne avec des recettes les
recettes ce sont les impôts et comme
vous le savez très bien dans les états
africains
l'économie est informel et l'assiette
pour recueillir les impôts est très très
très très très faible les ressources
minières et cetera avec la gestion qu'en
effet été souvent assez chaotique donc
aujourd'hui sans vouloir critiquer la
structure étatique des états africains
ils ont besoin de la dette c'est un
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui moi je
ne suis pas un comment dire un quelqu'un
de favorable à l'endettement mais c'est
une nécessité pour fonctionner pour
payer ses agents pour ses
infrastructures pour et c'est
l'éducation pour pour beaucoup de choses
la france s'endette les états européens
sans aide tous les états du monde sans
dette que ce soit sur les marchés privés
qui est il ya des états faut que vous et
ça à l'esprit à des états qui ne veulent
pas qu'on leur annuler leurs dettes
comme le nigeria et d'autres même le
rwanda et c'est pourquoi ils veulent pas
qu'on aura nul leur dette
parce que ils ont besoin de cette dette
et si demain on annule la dette
ils vont être très très mal notée sur
part justement toutes ses agences de
notation etc
et s'ils sont très mal notée ils
pourront plus pleuvait de la dette et
donc pour eux annulé des dettes ça ça
représente un danger pour eux ils ont
ils sont aidés des états qui sont plutôt
bien géré généralement ne veulent pas
qu'on leur annuler la dette qu'on l'a
rééchelonne que on trouve des solutions
pour en sortir petit à petit sans être
trop comment dire trop saigné
oui donc il faut il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on a ce qu'on dit
la dette ça n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose parce que quand c'est une
dette pour investir dans l'éducation
pour investir dans la dent dans les
infrastructures pour investir dans dans
la santé pour investir dans l'avenir
d'un pays
ce n'a pas ce n'est pas une bonne chose
la mauvaise dette c'est la dette qui
payent le fonctionnement qui paye des
fonctionnaires qui paye un peu là la
condition des états aujourd'hui qui sont
à majoritaire en afrique c'est à dire et
même j'ai envie de dire
premier lieu l'état français est un
français s'endettent pour payer de son
fonctionnement ce qui est en soi une
très mauvaise gestion donc le le constat
que je fais pour les pays africains je
le fais aussi pour la france
merci à tous les deux en tout cas m jid
el guerrab et makhoudia diouf d'avoir
accepté donc de débattre sur ce thème
faut-il annuler la dette des pays
africains merci à vous deux